[Música]
[Aplausos]
todo comenzó con una conversación
durante las fiestas de la parroquia una
amiga de la familia le explicó a mi
madre que su hijo iba los fines de
semana a un grupo de scouts católicos al
seno este servei de la abadía de
montserrat
los chavales subían un fin de semana al
mes al monasterio para ayudar en la
celebración de los oficios religiosos
no te preocupes mujer es una buena
experiencia son gente sana
los críos aprenden valores importantes
responsabilidad trabajo en equipo
servicio a la comunidad es más seguro
que dejar que tu hijo vaya los fines de
semana a una discoteca donde le pueden
dar drogas porque no le dices a miguel
que se anima se hubiera un fin de semana
seguro que le gusto
la amiga de mi madre tenía razón al
principio y me gustó
el monasterio de montserrat perdido en
medio la montaña es un lugar majestuoso
e imponente
sobre todo para mí que con 16 años
comenzaba independizarme de mis padres
durante cuatro décadas el grupo scout lo
había dirigido el monje andreu schüller
aparentemente un adulto de confianza
respetado tanto por los chavales como
por sus padres había formado ya a varias
generaciones de jóvenes catalanes
pero la realidad era otra
se trataba de un pederasta con piel de
cordero
un depredador sexual y pronto lo
descubrí en primera persona cuando me
convertí en una de sus múltiples
víctimas
como la mayoría de los abusadores no me
agredió inmediatamente nada más conocer
me primero se ganó mi confianza
te veo triste te pasa algo tienes algún
problema sabes que si necesitas hablar
estoy aquí para escuchar te puedes
confiar en mí y así comenzamos a
conversar primero de temas neutros
familia amigos estudios en zonas comunes
el comedor después de cenar
pero poco a poco la relación comenzó a
cambiar se convence se comenzó a meter
en mi cuarto por las noches me comenzó a
hablar de temas sexuales como la
masturbación
utilizando un tono pedagógico pretendía
quedarme clases prácticas de educación
sexual esto mejor no lo toques no es
bueno para ti me explicaba mientras te
metía su mano debajo del pantalón del
pijama y manosea a mis genitales
los abusos duraron un año
alarmado ante el riesgo de que mi
abusador pudiera reincidir le conté lo
que había pasado a mis padres éstos
escribieron una dura carta al abad de
montserrat quejándose de lo sucedido
ingenuamente pensé que la iglesia
reaccionaría denunciando al me abusador
a la policía intentando encontrar a
otras víctimas
que se comportarían de forma cristiana
como jesús hubiera hecho
me equivoqué
simplemente trasladaron a mi agresor a
un monasterio diferente y guardaron el
secreto
el abad de montserrat convenció a mis
padres que por el bien de todos lo mejor
era no presentar denuncia a la justicia
civil y dejar que la iglesia resolviera
internamente el problema
mis padres le creyeron les engaño
poco antes de morir la abadía de
montserrat publicó migres or un libro de
memorias en el que alardeaba y se
vanagloriaba de la gran labor que había
hecho educando a jóvenes católicos
durante 40 años
cuando lo descubrí no daba crédito fue
la gota que colmó el vaso de mi
paciencia me di cuenta que si las
víctimas no denunciamos los abusos
seguirán sucediendo
por eso en enero de 2019 harto de tanta
hipocresía e impunidad con térmicas son
los medios de comunicación
la historia como esta acabo de contar es
importante no porque sea excepcional
sino desgraciadamente porque no lo es
cientos de miles de historias similares
en todo el mundo nos han enseñado que el
problema de la pederastia y la iglesia
es estructural y sistémico no estamos
hablando de cuatro manzanas podridas el
cesto está podrido el vaticano ha
diseñado implementado y perpetuado un
sistema de justicia alternativo y
secreto
en la justicia civil violar a un niño se
considera un grave delito que debe ser
castigado con largas penas de prisión
en la justicia canónica se considera un
pecado que debe ser expirado con penas
de oración y penitencia
pasamos a un monaguillo no te preocupes
hijo un mal momento en la vida no tiene
cualquiera reza cinco padres nuestros y
diez avemarías yo te perdono hijo vete y
no peques más
pero por supuesto volvían a pecar una y
otra vez año tras año
parroquia tras parroquia aumentando
exponencial innecesariamente el número
de víctimas totales
este aberrante sistema solamente se ha
podido perpetuar hasta el día de hoy
porque ha existido una cultura
institucional que lo ha sustentado la
cultura de la pederastia clerical
y qué es exactamente la cultura de la
pederastia clerical
la podemos definir como el sistema de
creencias actitudes y comportamientos
compartidos por la mayoría de
integrantes de una comunidad religiosa
que facilita que se cometa y encubran
delitos de pederastia e imposibilita o
impide la denuncia de las víctimas
fue magistralmente reflejada en la
oscarizada película spotlight un secreto
a voces todo el mundo lo sabía pero
nadie hizo nada
porque sabéis de igual forma que es
necesaria una aldea para educar un niño
también se necesita una aldea para
abusar de él
las áreas abusadoras en boston en
cataluña o en cualquier lugar del mundo
comparten cinco características
principales
la primera es el secretismo
los abusos se consideran un tema tabú
que debe ser silenciado el sexo es
pecado
algo sucede grad ante que provoca culpa
y vergüenza si los niños no son capaces
de hablar abiertamente de sexualidad
cómo van a poder verbalizar los abusos y
se alude a algún crío que tiene la
imprudencia de contar a su entorno de
confianza qué es lo que ha sucedido este
inmediatamente le deja claro que de este
tema no se habla tienes que llevarte el
secreto a la tumba
aunque guardar el secreto te acabe
guardado llevando a la tumba
la segunda característica es la lealtad
a la institución la comunidad religiosa
profesa una lealtad ciega e
inquebrantable a la institución por
encima de la defensa de los derechos
individuales es más importante proteger
el poder el prestigio y el patrimonio de
la iglesia que garantizar el bienestar
de los menores
la tercera característica es la
culpabilización y estigmatización de la
víctima
la familia del niño percibe los abusos
como una mancha en el honor y en la
honra familiar les importa más mantener
su buen nombre social que proteger a sus
niños
si denunciamos en porte de gas ya que va
a pensar la vecina del quinto
la comunidad religiosa culpabiliza de lo
que ha sucedido a la víctima y no al
agresor
está mintiendo solo busca dinero porque
denuncia ahora después de tanto tiempo
porque no se defendió sí ya era mayor
cita
la cuarta característica es el
tribalismo
la comunidad religiosa adopta una
postura de nosotros frente a ellos la
iglesia es mi tribu ser católico forma
parte de mi identidad
por tanto cuando las víctimas los
periodistas o los abogados denuncian el
problema me siento personalmente
agredido y reaccionó con hostilidad
denunciar la pederastia clerical no es
hacer limpieza es atacar a la iglesia
la quinta y última característica es el
clericalismo existe una clara jerarquía
de poder en la institución una marcada
asimetría entre los niños y los
religiosos
se pone a los sacerdotes en un pedestal
sobre una figura sagrada intocable los
representantes de dios en la tierra son
incapaces de cometer un delito semejante
y si lo han hecho es porque han caído en
la tentación porque los niños van
provocando
de esta forma se genera una casta
sacerdotal aparte que no tiene que
seguir las normas de la justicia civil
como hacemos los simples mortales la
cárcel la dejamos para el que robó una
gallina
afortunadamente la cultura de la
pederastia clerical que acabo de
escribir no es inmutable
las sociedades cambian y evolucionan se
adaptan a los nuevos tiempos esto es lo
que ha comenzado a pasar en nuestro país
en los últimos años gracias a la
valentía de las víctimas al denunciar
los abusos
a partir de ahora los ciudadanos tendrán
que tomar una elección van a ser
espectadores pasivos o participantes
activos este cambio cultural en marcha
los individuos tenemos una relación
bidireccional con la cultura en la que
vivimos
todos somos influenciados por ella pero
al mismo tiempo todos tenemos la
capacidad de transformarla
porque las culturas cambian de
conversación en conversación
por eso me gustaría hacer es una
petición no os conforméis con escucharme
animaros a participar es más sencillo de
lo que parece cuando acabe esta
conferencia y volváis a vuestros hogares
a vuestros barrios y a vuestras
comunidades atreveros a tener una
conversación sobre este tema con vuestro
entorno una conversación que potencie
este cambio cultural en marcha
enseñar a nuestros hijos la regla del
bañador que ningún adulto puede tocar
las partes íntimas que están cubiertos
por el traje de baño organizar una
charla de prevención en el colegio de
nuestros niños hay expertos que estarán
dispuestos a ayudarlos y madres y padres
deseosos de aprender más sobre este tema
escribir al director del periódico
alabando la valentía de las víctimas y
exigiendo que las autoridades civiles y
religiosos tomen medidas sobre este tema
difundir una noticia en redes sociales
que ayuda a visibilizar el problema
hablar con el moción de nuestra
parroquia preguntarle qué media se está
tomando la diócesis para prevenir los
abusos y apoyar a las víctimas o mejor
preguntárselo al obispo
comentar con vuestros amigos y
familiares un libro una película un
documental que hayáis visto leído
recientemente sobre el tema
a lo mejor las acciones que os acaba de
proponer os parecen insuficientes
permitidme que os diga que no es con
estos pequeños pero significa tan
significativos gestos cómo se cambia una
cultura
hablando con nuestros hijos y amigos
rompiendo el silencio visibilizando un
tema tabú
juntos somos más poderosos de lo que
creemos
esta última afirmación no es un brindis
al sol ni es una promesa voluntarista al
contrario es una postura pragmática y
realista es como históricamente se han
producido la mayor parte de las
transformaciones sociales hemos
aprendido en los países más avanzados de
nuestro entorno que la sociedad civil
siempre tiene un papel de liderazgo a la
hora de transformar la cultura
institucional de la iglesia el cambio
siempre ha llegado de abajo arriba nunca
de arriba abajo
tras 30 años de crisis podemos afirmar
con certeza que el vaticano y los
obispos son incapaces de reformarse si
no es bajo una fuerte presión interna y
externa
en todos los países se ha seguido el
mismo patrón de cambio se comienza con
una minoría de víctimas pioneras que
tienen la valentía de anunciar los
abusos que ha sufrido en los medios y la
justicia esa denuncia genera una fuerte
controversia social entre partidarios y
detractores las víctimas tienen que
soportar la reacción abiertamente hostil
pasiva o indiferente de una parte
significativa de la sociedad pero sabéis
igual forma que el miedo es contagioso
también lo es la valentía se produce un
efecto multiplicador las víctimas se
animan a denunciar más periodistas
apuestan por informar más jueces
policías y fiscales deciden investigar
se genera un círculo virtuoso que
comienza a decantar el equilibrio de
poder a favor de las víctimas
los obispos comienzan a perder apoyos
cada vez tienen menos aliados y más
detractores
esta pérdida de poder anima a las
víctimas más resistentes a dar un paso
al frente hasta que por fin se alcanza
una masa crítica de denuncias lo cual ya
genera una dinámica de cambio social
imparable los políticos se dan cuenta
que la postura más segura ya no es
defender a ultranza el status quo sino
abanderar la reforma y el cambio se
comienzan a cambiar leyes como los
plazos de prescripción en los delitos de
pederastia
por último los obispos aislados y sin
apoyo no tienen más remedio que acometer
profundas reformas ante la fuerte
presión judicial social y periodística
se ha producido una transformación
cultural hemos pasado de una cultura de
la pederastia clerical a una cultura de
la protección a la infancia
antes de acabar me gustaría haceros una
confesión
a pesar de todas las dificultades y
decepciones que me encontrado en el
camino
sigo teniendo un sueño
sueño que en el futuro cuando una
víctima tenga la valentía de denunciar
los abusos que ha sufrido en la iglesia
la reacción mayoritaria de la sociedad
no sea cuestionar su testimonio y
preguntar en tono acusador
porque no te defendiste porque no has
denunciado antes
sueño con vivir en una sociedad donde
ante una injusticia semejante los
ciudadanos hagamos examen de conciencia
y nos preguntemos que hemos hecho mal
porque no te protegimos porque no te
escuchamos antes
sueño con vivir en una sociedad con una
mentalidad civilizada ilustrada propia
del siglo 21 una sociedad donde por fin
todos tengamos claro que la culpa de la
pederastia y la iglesia la tienen
siempre siempre los curas abusadores y
los obispos encubridores
nuestros niños
una sociedad donde nos importe más
garantizar la seguridad y el bienestar
de nuestros pequeños que proteger el
poder el prestigio y el patrimonio de
una institución
en qué sociedad quieres vivir
[Aplausos]